we have a very talented roster we have a
very Talent team but the reason we have
a chance to be great is we're really
good at grinding
I always think the best CEOs are
grinders yes you have to have a vision
yes you got to set a culture but the
best ones are it's not about them it's
the grinding
grinding it's a concept that resonates
in the blue color town of Philadelphia a
city that loves its football team
they'll even spell it out for you
I think philadelphians are just eager
for any type of joy that we can get I
will say that our level of booing
sef's kiss
best in the world
while Eagles fans are Infamous the
team's owner Jeffrey Laurie May at first
glance seem like the polar opposite to
the Philly faithful a PhD wielding
Hollywood film producer who grew up in
Boston that's not what many have deemed
a Philly guy
and in his time he has made some
unpopular decisions the Philadelphia
Eagles select
Galen hurts
[Music]
we're not risk averse and we never want
to be risk-averse whether it's on the
football field or off and that allows
you to have this culture that can
achieve some successes continuously he's
not your typical owner and so he's not
going to think or operate like all the
other owners in his nearly 30 years with
the team he's gone from being the
youngest owner in the league to a
standard bearer of what modern NFL
ownership looks like we're stewards of
something incredibly popular let's run
it well but at the same time let's
really make a big difference in in the
communities and across the country and
maximize our our love for each other
foreign
[Music]
Street in South Philadelphia sits the
Eagles Nova Care complex I'm here today
to meet with their owner Jeffrey Laurie
now if you're outside of Philadelphia
you might not know his name and that's
not an accident or an oversight
Lori hasn't been one to sit down for
long interviews in the past but I wanted
to understand how he views himself his
businesses and the future of running a
pro football team
you know as I was thinking about you and
and preparing for this it struck me this
is not a franchise that has these
massive highs and and then like stunning
lows as it were there's a consistency to
it
how do you create both a culture and an
organization that is able to sustain
so not easy and I think what we were
able to do early on is establish that
culture
that culture is very intense
hard-working blue-collar culture within
an organization that's very focused on
the key things that drive success
Jeffrey Lurie has owned the eagle since
1994. it's an investment that you'd have
to say has paid off for him bought the
team for just under 200 million dollars
and estimates today put the team at 4.9
billion dollars one of the things that
I've found to be true in pro football
probably to a greater degree than the
average fan realizes is that ownership
really has an effect on the team
if you have a good owner then you have a
real chance to win if you have a bad
owner
it just poisons the whole organization
ownership Styles vary around the league
to say the least maybe best illustrated
by the owners within the Eagle's own
division the New York football Giants
have been owned by the mara family and
their offspring for nearly 100 years
it's a family business passed down
through generations down in DC the newly
renamed Washington commanders are for
the moment owned by Dan Snyder
Snyder is to say the least unpopular
[Applause]
tenure has been plagued by accusations
of personal and financial misconduct
leading to Federal investigations and
calls even from fellow owners to sell
the team which he may finally do
then in Dallas you have Jerry Jones I
hope there's some Cowboy fans here maybe
the most recognizable Sports owner on
the planet he has successfully marketed
the Cowboys into being the most valuable
sporting franchise ever the team was
valued by sportico at a staggering 7.6
billion dollars in 2022 there are all
sorts of different owners I mean some
owners like the visibility some owners
get into this because they love the
visibility after games
he stands in the middle of the locker
room and people go to him before they go
to the coaches and players in some cases
and he loves that and Jeffrey is on the
other side of that if I'm tuning in to
sports radio you know you're not doing a
a WIP call-in show you are I mean this
in and of itself is pretty rare for you
to sit down and have an extended
conversation
is that your personality is it a
business Choice like why why sort of
take that approach so you know for me
it's not wanting to it's much more
wanting to embrace the fans directly not
through Gatekeepers
so I always saw Sports Talk Radio as
interesting valuable to um you know for
fans but it's a very different business
we're in the business of trying to win
big have a great organization represent
the community in a great way we're not
into wanting to monetize drama that's in
stark contrast to Jerry Jones whose
strategy has meant repeatedly placing
and finding himself at the center of
every conversation and controversy tied
to his team whether he means to or not
financially it's worked out despite the
team only winning three playoff games in
the last 25 years
Lori's Farm or reserved approach puts
him in a more familiar setting behind
the camera and local residents they're
more than happy for the spotlight
I think the fans are the star of the
show
my name is Amir Questlove Thompson I am
a musician member of The Roots a
director and a proud Philadelphia
quick time out here Questlove
we're gonna get more into this later but
beyond being a Philadelphia native
six-time Grammy award-winning musician
author and podcaster he's also a film
director he won his first Oscar for his
first movie a film called Summer of Soul
which Jeffrey Lurie executive produced
in his other business documentary
filmmaking
but for now let's get back to those
Eagles fans
[Music]
even though it's a Cosmopolitan City
it's really a blue collar town
it's the wolf in sheep's clothing it's
it's a blue collared town in the image
rape of a Cosmopolitan City we're
elegant but we also might have a pack of
batteries uh inside the inside pockets
[Music]
I did after we won the Super Bowl was
get this Eagles lip tattooed whether
it's lip tattoos with the score of Super
Bowl 52 getting arrested go Eagles or
whatever this is
it's uh passionate fan base that is
gonna let you know how they feel even
while rescuing children from fires my
man just start throwing babies out the
window we was catching them unlike
Aguilar local news Stars aside with such
a vocal fan base Lori has often gone
against popular wisdom with the second
pick the Philadelphia Eagles select
Donovan McNabb quarterback Syracuse
University
and while some decisions like taking
quarterback Donovan McNabb over running
back Ricky Williams worked out others
not so much the Philadelphia Eagles
select Jalen rager I've never wanted to
make popular decisions I kind of grew up
in Boston with a baseball team at the
time that always kind of made popular
decisions and they always kind of ended
up not doing very well and I always
thought you know if I ever had the
chance to run or own a team don't ever
try to make popular decisions try to
make what you think is best if we're
gonna have to change a coach
it's going to be changed for a great
reason for a coach that can provide
provide something that's been missing if
it's a player mistake don't continue to
make that investment in that player
mistake but move on have a sort of a
self-critical nature about that's part
of the culture I think that's been one
of our keys to success is we we pay very
little attention to the outside noise
and recognize some of it is true some of
it's not true and the best thing you can
do is do what you think is right and
recently for NFL owners doing the right
thing goes beyond the football field
[Music]
NFL team facilities tend to be shrines
to the players and personalities of the
team's past but right as you enter
you'll notice something a little
different about the NovaCare complex a
wall of Heroes honoring Martin Luther
King Jr Nelson Mandela and Dr Paul
Farmer
this is not the typical entrance to a to
a football facility very early on after
owning the team I thought you know the
values we really want to present to our
players our employees our everybody
involved in it is football is incredible
it's the most popular sport in America
but let the values be even bigger we're
out there we're out there to have a
great practice you know we're singularly
focused on the next play the next
practice the next game and yet our lives
were human beings and this is a chance
to kind of put it all in perspective and
it doesn't take away from being hyper
competitive it makes you want to make a
difference whether it's on the football
field or off I think it UPS your odds on
on winning well overluri's tenure the
Eagles have taken up a number of causes
all around the Philadelphia area more
recently Laurie's focused his
philanthropic efforts closer to home on
autism research
thank you all for being here today and
for your unwavering commitment to
helping improve the lives of those
impacted by autism you know I hesitate
for a long time integrating my
wanting to try to make an impact in the
world of autism because of my brother
um and the family business so to speak
it became something where I wasn't
needing to like push it aside but saying
you know what we could be a sports team
that absolutely identifies with a
underfunded condition that affects
Millions around the world and kind of
make it so that there's no real
difference between the Eagles
and autism as you notice at the end of
every end zone we have Eagles autism
foundation so every time there's a TV
shot of a score a field goal whatever's
going on the Eagles and autism are
synonymous that was my goal because that
allows us to reach
millions of people it allows us to have
terrific fundraising it's amazing to see
our players and everybody want to be
part of it philanthropy across the
entire NFL is also changing spurred by a
Workforce the players who have louder
voices and higher expectations
today's NFL occupies a unique and
important place in American culture
reflecting often in Stark terms the
biggest opportunities and challenges
great wealth and individual success
right alongside a history that includes
systematic racism sexism and abusive
power the past several years have seen
NFL players fight for voting rights
equality and more by leveraging their
Fame and influence
do you feel the expectations have been
raised for for ownership during the
during your tenure as an owner I do I do
in a good way I think we're really
challenged to be good really good
Community examples and let's not just be
worthy NFL we're so successful we
dominate television our valuations are
gigantic let's absolutely be the best
citizens we can be and let's judge
ourselves not just on the field but off
the field
luries also leaned into the interest of
his players when it comes to social
issues most notably in the recent past
with Malcolm Jenkins are you not going
to say anything today or just going to
use these posters
I cherish having you know players like
Malcolm I encourage players to be really
Community involved I always really
enjoyed his ability to Think Through
what he wanted to accomplish and then
set a series of short-term mechanisms to
do it we're here to use our leverage our
voices to make sure that our families
our communities our kids are a priority
to continuing this Legacy of using the
NFL as a platform for change quarterback
Jalen hurts has been raising awareness
around gun violence all with the support
and amplification of the Eagles I think
the the more important thing is the
platform we have and the opportunity we
have to impact the people around us
there there's definitely an intersection
between sports entertainment and popular
culture it's up to us the leaders in
those Industries to be able to celebrate
the beauty that we have and attack the
problems that we have because there's
real problems of poverty inequality
social injustice these are real yet at
the same time let's celebrate the
wonderful people that we have lury's own
off-field platform making movies allows
him another Avenue to advance important
conversations his films document seminal
but often little-known moments in
American history stories that give voice
to our Collective complicated
relationship with race inequality
and the winner is
summer of Soul when the revolution could
not be televised a myth Thompson
and four white guys
so here's a funny thing
so the normal protocol especially with
documentaries is you usually just have
like one benefactor like one one
producer one person to finance it this
film was very unusual in the fact that
everyone sort of wanted in on the action
and when I saw the name uh Jeff Laurie I
was like
nah it's not him anyway and went on and
I saw the name again and I was like wait
isn't this a guy that owns the Eagles
and they're like yeah
I was like wait he's in the movie
business who knew like I
I had zero clue
the movie industry was the family
business for Jeffrey Laurie his
grandfather Philip Smith was an
entrepreneur in the movie theater
business he helped popularize the
drive-in and the Suburban shopping mall
theater
it's interesting when you parallel and
look at you know what I'm doing now but
it was all focused on making the
enjoyment of watching like the fan of
movies enjoy their experience so big
beautiful screens clean bathrooms easy
parking this was his way in to try to
get people to appreciate storytelling
Lori has produced some narrative films
over the years but of late documentary
has been the effort of his company play
action pictures
Lori received his third Oscar for summer
of Seoul it got presented to us as this
is a project would you like to help from
the very beginning with Questlove and
we've got access to the archives of all
this music and we just thought it was a
perfect project for us and often we will
take
stories that happen history that
happened that has a very very real
present day
relevance like I've seen rubber stamping
in the industry especially with the
executive producers
you know talk to my people they'll
explain and I'll do the final signature
yep it's good to go Jeff is really
really passionate about movies and you
know he had notes uh for every
rough draft that we sent you know we did
at least five cuts of Summer of Seoul
his notes were front and center
Festival built around never seen footage
of the 1969 Harlem cultural Festival
summer of Seoul ultimately tells a story
not just of an amazing lineup of artists
but of what their hidden history says
about America then and now it started
out just as a cool mixtape of
performances
and then it wound up
really being a life lesson it was one
where I love showing it to our players
um they were in most cases like shocked
at the late 60s and what was going on
both in the country and the humanity of
it so a lot of the parallels here of of
owning a team having a documentary film
company is to explore the humanity and
Elevate the value of human beings that
really need to be elevated as an example
in society for all of us and it strikes
me that that
Outlook philosophy ethos however you
want to describe it you know it comes
into sharp relief in the summer of 2020.
protests over the death of George Floyd
while in police custody now in their
eighth night the remarkable scenes that
have been unfolding in cities across
this country yet again
there's a lot of your work that starts
to come to a very fine point at that
moment your worlds are colliding to to
some extent in terms of what you've done
as a filmmaker and what you're doing as
the owner of this franchise take me back
to that summer so
obviously very difficult summer but not
atypical
um there's a lot of taking down of black
citizens all across the country every
every day every week but you know a
terribly polarized time in America and a
lot of anger coming out suddenly the
very issues that were we were dealing
with in 1969
we were also dealing with those same
exact issues 50 years later I will say
that this entire decade from 2020 on
will be sort of a new establishment and
a new uh beginning
for
the platform and who gets to speak on
that platform
while Lurie continues to work with
players and filmmakers in areas of
representation on the football field the
Eagles have also played a key role in
elevating black players to the most
coveted role in the game the quarterback
position
entering the 2022 season the Eagles had
the most games started by a black
quarterback in the history of the NFL
with 360. in comparison their rival the
New York Giants had only one ever
you know first of all we're trying to
get the best possible quarterback so
it's not in any way well okay this
person is uh is black or whatever that
that's never been the case we always
want to get the best player on the other
hand whatever I'm involved in I think
there's a feeling of sort of undervalued
certainly felt that with Donovan McNabb
nobody had ever drafted a black
quarterback that high in the history of
the NFL at the time number two we were
lucky to get them I mean we were so
lucky that the team who had the first
pick
undervalued him his mobility and his
ability to be dynamic on the field we're
probably undervalued by that team and
and goes on and on with Michael Vick it
was more this man deserves a second
chance the the things he got involved in
were awful you know I described him as
heinous with dogs and I'm a dog lover
but we felt in America at that time and
and still to today
often black people don't get Second
Chances
and this was a man who was very talented
that's why he was getting a second
chance but also because we believed his
desire to make good on some of the you
know things that he caused a lot of pain
were real and and Michael proved us to
be right for giving him the second
chance so there's there's a history to
to Randall to Donovan we have Rodney
Pete I could add Jalen hurts to that
just just all excellent people comes
down to it excellent people who probably
were undervalued and so whether it's
black musicians in the 60s or
quarterbacks in the you know 90s and
2000s there's a similarity
foreign
so I feel like we've been like leading
up to to a moment where I ask you sort
of one of these big sweeping questions
what's your advice as the as the future
of the NFL unfolds for someone who is
coming into this now
well first of all come into it if you
love the sport don't come into it like
you're just running a business it's not
the same number two manage your team to
the best of your ability and not what
outside world influences those are
short-term influences don't pay
attention to that stuff don't try to be
popular that's that'll create
unpopularity basically in the long run
Lori's giving that kind of advice in
real time to his son Julian who has
worked for the NFL and recently joined
the Eagles full-time in a business and
football operation strategy role Laurie
senior having grown up in another family
business has turned the Eagles into his
own and plans to pass it down with an
expectation that his children will run
it with the same attention but it feels
like 30 40 years ago you could sort of
be a gentleman owner right you could
just sort of like rock up to your
Stadium on Sundays I'm sure today no way
no and you won't be successful you got
to be really passionate and feel that
Weekly ultra competitive nature and it's
also what makes it great yeah I love
that competitive juices you're not
manufacturing widgets you are
trying to maximize human beings even
better than the movies even better than
the movies even much better than the
movies yeah